[Musik]
sascha otto sie sind unser bester mann
roger rabbit ist der typische fall einer
ns komödie die ziemlich große brille da
durchgekommen ist das natürlich alle
sobald hitler auf einem film bild
auftaucht sich fragen wie ernst ist das
gemeint natürlich kannst du und wenn es
dann auch noch ein komischer hitler ist
wie es nun ganz ohne zweifel hier der
fall ist dann stellt sich diese frage
noch mal verschärft das ist schon seit
chaplins großen diktator so und damit
hat tag arbeitet der regisseur und
darsteller des hitler in georgia wird
natürlich auch wieder seine probleme
gehabt
was ist ein kleiner mann von dem
kaninchen vorfall erzählen was war denn
da los
sie wollten das ist töte ich konnte es
nicht
mach dir keinen kopf das ist mir schnurz
egal aber jetzt nennen sie mich ein
hasenfuß
sollen sie doch sagen was sie wollen
über mich haben die leute haufenweise
diese dinge gesagt hat er kann ist
wahnsinnig sieht das nur diesen psycho
andermatt tag alle umbringen
andererseits ist der film in amerika
super angekommen in der neuseeländischen
heimat von waikiki sowieso und ich halte
ihn auch für eine ausgesprochen
geglückte arbeit insofern als da das
lachen als waffe gegen den
totalitarismus eingesetzt wird und das
auf eine so wunderbar kluge und auch so
genau beobachtet was die aufnahme von
propaganda sprache oder auch von
bestimmten slogans der nazis angeht dass
ich sagen würde dass es vielleicht sogar
bisher eines der schönsten beispiele für
komödiantischen umgang mit dem ns-staat
[Musik]
handlung von george david ist ungefähr
die folgende ein zehnjähriger junge in
einem fiktiven provinz dorf namens
falkenheim kommt ins jung volk und soll
sich danach unter nazi ideologie als
hart wie kruppstahl und zäh wie leder
und und schnell wie den tunnel bewähren
und das alles schafft er nicht und der
wirkliche deckt dieses films liegt darin
dass er eine art schlechtes gewissen hat
und das sieht aus wie adolf hitler nur
er kann dieses schlechte gewissen sehen
ist aber dauernd im gespräch mit diesem
schlechten gewissen und das gewissen
versucht ihn einzuschwören auf die werte
des ns systems das klingt
selbstverständlich und dieser darsteller
des zehnjährigen jungen ein erst links
auftritt eines im original auch nur
glaube ich ein zwei jahre älteren kinder
darstellers ist absolut sensationell
ich kenne den namen immer noch nicht
komplett ich weiß nur dass er davis mit
nachnamen heißt die vornamen habe ich
mir nicht gemerkt aber das ist eines der
schönsten kinderschauspieler debüts was
ich überhaupt bisher gesehen habe und
wenn man denn überhaupt keinen grund hat
in diesem film reinzugehen sich dem
anzusehen das wäre wirklich einer
sie sind schuld daran dass mein sohn
nicht richtig laufen kann und noch im
gesicht
also sie werden auf ihn aufpassen
während ich arbeite sie geben ihm eine
aufgabe der mitte sich zugehörig fühlt
angekommen angekommen
haiti ist ein regisseur der mit komödien
in neuseeland groß geworden ist kommt
eigentlich aus dem komödianten business
also comedian war auf der bühne stand up
comedian und hat dann einige sehr
hübsche filme über neuseeländischen
alltag gemacht aber in sehr skurrile art
und weise hat dann ein ganz
hervorragender vampir parodie gemacht
die auf der berlinale mit großem erfolg
gelaufen ist und das hat ihm so viel
renommee verschafft dass er einen tor
film angeboten bekam und den auch
gedreht hat den dritten tor film den ich
zugegebener weise das glück dass im tor
film gefunden habe was damit zu tun hat
dass der humor von weitem nicht in allen
bereichen funktioniert da sein
nationalsozialismus besser funktioniert
als in der superhelden welt hat mich
überrascht aber auch erfreut weil er da
glaube ich rücksichtsloser mit den
figuren umgehen
kann auf die superhelden muss man immer
noch gewisser weise rücksicht nehmen
weil da viele viele gefühle verletzt
werden
mit nazis raus oben geht der muss sich
nicht allzu viel sorge um beifall von
der falschen seite machen und
dementsprechend ist das hier der wildere
der auch unbequemere film in dem was da
humoristisch gebrochen wird und darum
auch der viel besseren irgendwann lernt
sich jemand besonderes kennen wieso
sagen wir dass alle dauern
wer sagt dir dass dennoch einfach die da
jedenfalls ist das ein dummer gedanke du
bist du liebe ist das stärkste auf der
welt du wirst doch zugeben das metall
das dax auf der welt ist dicht gefolgt
von dynamit und dann muskeln die
oscar-nominierung für jutta witt ist für
mich eine überraschung komödien haben es
normalerweise schwer in diesem segment
und bester film zeigt allerdings auch
weil das ja eine rubrik ist in der viele
filme aufgenommen sind im gegensatz zu
den meisten anderen rubriken dass er da
zwar mitunter gekommen ist aber nicht
beispielsweise bei tt als regisseur
nominiert ist auch die hauptdarsteller
sind nicht nominiert das heißt das ist
zwar eine anerkennung für die machart
des films auch sicherlich für den erfolg
in der film in amerika gehabt hat aber
er ist wirklich absolut chancenlos in
diesem oscar-rennen es hat mich einfach
nur gefreut weil hollywood damit zeigt
dass sie große achtung vor dieser arbeit
[Applaus]
du wirst du schneller wachsen
zehnjährige sollten nicht den krieg
bejubeln und über politik reden den film
sollten alle leute sehen die wirklich
mal etwas humoristisches sehen wollen
und nicht allzu viele bedenken haben
wenn das ganze im dritten reich spielt
und wie gesagt die rollen sind ganz klar
schwarz weiß verteilt man muss ich
überhaupt keine sorge um die eigene
moral machen
da wird mit den nazis schlecht
umgegangen und die deutschen haben keine
chance und es gibt einige anständige
deutsche so gesehen auch das eigene gute
gewissen beruhigt und das schlechte
gewissen ja gut das kann man sich dann
nachher machen wenn einen der film dann
nicht gefallen hat dann fürchte ich ganz
offen gestanden hat man vom kino
humoristen da sein doch nicht allzu viel
ahnung
[Musik]
j
und gott es ist alles keinen sinn mehr
du sagst es ist sicher keine gute zeit
um ein nazi zu sein